hi there we need to talk about gan
generated faces after we spotted this
paper beautifully entitled i still all
ah when did paper titles become this
sketchy i personally do not have any
trouble with making research sexy as
long as there is no all you need in
titles anymore as you have already
guessed this paper is highlighting that
gan generated images at least with style
gun too do not render the pupil
accurately enough and therefore one can
build a gan generated face detector upon
this feature miss coffee bean saw this
paper received an enormous amount of
attention on twitter with reactions
ranging from dismissing the importance
of this pupil feature because the next
gan generation will fix this problem
anyway to cases of surprise that gans
did not capture this human feature so
what are the implications of this paper
that highlights the pupil feature in
particular and more generally how to
tell gan generated images apart from
real ones this is what we will discuss
in this ai coffee break
hey do you have your coffee ready
because now we begin this paper here
highlights a problem in gan generated
phases gan stands for generative
adversarial networks if you want a
refresher of how gans work to produce
images check out our previous high level
explanation about this so the authors
investigate how gans failed to generate
circular or analytically shaped pupils
for human eyes therefore the authors
propose a method to automatically
estimate the shape of pupils and
determine if it is human-like enough
since gans tend to generate weird pupil
shapes this should automatically detect
whether the depicted person is real or
generated by again but miss coffeebean
sees here two categories of problems
let's go to problem number one
the paper is framed like gans in general
have this property of generating weirdly
shaped pupils but if we look closely
into the experimental section we see
that the authors have quantitatively
estimated this property only with style
gun 2. so to generalize to gan generated
in general is a bit of a sneaky
exaggeration do not get us wrong here it
is absolutely the case that many other
gans have the same problems with pure
pills too at least when we zoom in a lot
from his coffee bean the pupil problem
is not even that strong in this case
which is strange because the authors
reportedly used exactly the same cool
website this person does not exist.com
do check it out to retrieve some style
gan two generations in any case gan
generation quality is not there yet
where details are rendered well just
look at the eyebrows and eyelashes too
these little details are easy to
overlook if these gan generated images
are used in settings where pictures are
not looked at in full detail for example
in bot accounts on social media where
the profile picture is so tiny anyway
so understandably there is need for an
automatic bot checker as the authors
propose but the argument of using this
pupil detector widely grows weaker
because style gun 2 won't be nvidia's
last generation of gans ever and other
parties are training powerful gans too
especially since gan generated face
detection is an arms race now that the
defenders know of this pupil feature the
attackers will do their best to make the
right generations in the next version
circumventing automatic gun generated
face detectors so what we can learn from
this paper so far is that when zooming
in and looking at the tiny details we
see problems in gang generations it's
not really news that tiny coherent
structure is hard to enforce look at the
details of hair everything about the
eyes
teeth or tongue or lips for example miss
coffee bean should we write the paper
now lips tell it all i'm just kidding
but coherent structure over larger
distances is even harder especially for
elements with highest diversity in the
images in the training set we argue that
pupils would be the first ones to be
fixed in gang generation really because
that feature occurs in most of the
phases but structures spanning longer
distances in the image that are only
exhibited by a subset of the data is far
more problematic just look at the
background that is highly diverse in the
training data and should be diverse in
the generations too it seldomly makes
sense unless it's uniform like where is
this person even situated or look at the
ears for example which are not often
featured both in images because of the
lateral angle or hair covering them up
this picture was generated by style gun
2 2 and look how the ear lobes are at
different heights but sure all these
problems are not that easy for automatic
detection with handcrafted features like
the pupils are a funny side note the
problem with the style gun generating
bad pupils is weird perhaps unexpected
but it's well known that neural networks
tend to pay attention to very weird tiny
features like tiny details between
animal species when it comes to their
fur structure while being sloppy on more
obvious features for humans like
learning that dogs usually have for legs
they surprise us negatively as much as
positively personally i was astonished
when learning that neural nets even pay
attention to visual chirality being able
to tell whether an image has been
mirrored or not by judging from things
that are statistically more often
encountered in one mirror ring than in
the other like buttons on men's shirts
for more check out our video now let's
get to the problem number two of this
method
the authors acknowledge that detecting
how elliptical a pupil is could
discriminate against people who just
happen to have not circular pupils the
authors come with no real suggestion
here to circumvent the problem and say
that it is an infrequent phenomenon and
abnormal pupils were not found in the
real images of the datasets they used
consisting of professional photographs
that this dataset doesn't contain any
abnormal pupils does not mean anything
to miss coffee bean since this could be
due to any kind of selection bias
therefore she would like to stress the
warning here not to use only an ipupil
normality checker if at all otherwise
imagine people being told sorry we don't
allow you to create your tinder account
because our anti-gann ai tells us that
you have robot shaped pupils bye so what
to conclude
that humans given enough image
resolution and knowing where to look for
errors can still know if an image is
gang generated or not but the gan that
is making detection humanly impossible
is not really that far away from now so
we need automatic methods that detect
those a method based on strangely shaped
pupils is useful for now for style gun 2
and its likes but is short-lived like so
many things in machine learning what
miss coffee bean likes about this paper
is that it puts things into perspective
for non-machine learning experts let us
know what you think about the paper in
the comments and do not forget to like
and subscribe
[Music]